he's a psychologist at New York
University's Stern School of Business
and co-author New York Times best seller
the coddling of the American mind how
good intentions and bad ideas are
setting up a generation for failure
Jonathan hight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's get right to this and see how this
all folds in together now the last thing
we need in this country is another
reason for democracy to be threatened
but your book says we have fun it's that
darn kids today explain that a little on
paraphrasing you're an actual eminent
professor you say it in better words
than I just did please sure well the the
book has its origins in an observation
from my co-author Gregg lukianov he is
the president of the foundation for
individual rights and education defends
free speech rights on campus and in 2013
Gregg began noticing that for the first
time it was the students who were asking
for protections from words and books and
ideas and speakers previously students
had protested speakers before but they'd
never before medicalised it they acted
as though if this person says something
I will be harmed damaged people will be
traumatized and so this was something
new and when they put in terms of safety
well then administrators have to respond
so this came in around 2013 2014 and it
brought with it a whole package of
innovations you might say
microaggression training safe spaces
trigger warnings all this stuff appears
from out of nowhere around 2013-2014
that's something I did not realize until
I was reading your book I thought it
went back further cuz I've been talking
about the fragile stuff for a long time
but I didn't realize that this is a new
generation the Millennials stop at 1995
1994 that's right okay so now we're into
the ijen you call them or Generation Z
same thing that's right and they're even
more fragile yeah well so this is
something can we blame let's start
blaming I want to blame let's play let's
play the blame game okay I say okay
we'll do all the parents and we'll do
all the all the teachers so yeah the
basic the basic finding which I think
surprised a lot of us a lot of us
assumed that the Millennials were from
1982 to around 2000 or 1998 but kids
born around 1995 had a very different
childhood from kids born a few years
before and so research by Jean Jean
Twenge another show that kids born after
1985 they don't get driver's licenses as
much they don't drink as much they don't
go out on dates they don't have sex as
much what are they doing they're sitting
at home on their devices talking with
each other and this seems to be changing
social development
and we know this this is not just some
you know perception from outsiders
because the rates of anxiety disorders
depression self-cutting where they have
to be admitted to hospitals and suicide
all of these rates are way way up
especially for girls and it all begins
right around 2011 and so it's when this
generation first enters college campuses
and 2013 that's when all this new
attitude about speech comes in isn't
another reason that they're sitting home
instead of doing all those fun things is
because the parents insist on watching
them all the time exactly I mean we
talked I remember 20 years ago we talked
about helicopter parents you know
hovering over them and now they call it
bulldozer
parents yep yeah they clear out any
obstacles in the Sierras parenting I've
heard right yeah so that the kid doesn't
have to ever face any difficulties how
can that kid function in the real world
that's right so the the most important
psychological idea in the book is
antifragility that there's some things
that are fragile like a wineglass if you
knock it over it breaks nothing good
happens if something is plastic you
knock it over it doesn't get damaged but
doesn't get better but there's some
things that have to be stressed or
challenged like the immune system if you
protect your kids immune system use
bacterial wipes you're actually hurting
the kid you're preventing the system
from getting the information right needs
same thing with social life if you
protect your kids from being excluded
from being insulted from being teased
when they grow up it's like The Princess
and the pea a little tiny thing that
they encounter on campus
now becomes intolerably painful but it's
not all over the country really is it I
mean it's well it this is something when
they talk about elites this is who we're
talking about I think a little more yeah
the heartland look at the kids who are
[ __ ] you mom you know I call him the
[ __ ] you mom generation I might make
these jorts yeah I mean calling mom a
[ __ ] turning their back on what their
mother's talking if I did that I would
not be sitting here today
[Applause]
we you know the constant negotiating
with the with the kids you know hey
buddy
ya ready to go that's right kids kids
need structure and authority and when
parents try too hard to be their friends
yeah but but on the point about whether
this is everywhere so this is such a new
trend we only begin to notice these
things in the last couple years but what
seems to be the case is that the anxiety
and depression the fragility the mental
illness that's across the country across
social classes across races and that's
why social media use is beginning early
beginning in middle school that seems to
be the most likely culprit of several
culprits so that's all over the country
but the the the shout downs the the
screaming at professors we've mapped
that out that is almost only in the
Northeast and just the coastal strip of
the west coast and a loop in Chicago but
that's what gets the headlines and
that's what dominates media the see it's
the kid who's screaming at the professor
who then gets a job at The Huffington
Post that's right and provides fodder
for that for rising media to say look
how terrified the problem with liberals
in general is that they let those kids
who are at the Huffington Post or
whatever writing their insane woke [ __ ]
they let them control the debate just
like the parents let the kid control
when we're leaving we've let the kids
take over
that's like job one you don't do in
civilizations that's right there has you
respect the elders that's like every
civilization before this one because
they might be wise like
you know to connect it to this point of
why we lose
I think that's relevant I think people
in this country don't anymore pay
attention to policy so much it's more
this personal stuff it's anecdotal I
don't know about global warming or what
causes the recession but you know I saw
that mother at the soccer game or in the
supermarket and her five-year-old was
screaming at her and she was apologizing
to the five-year-old I'm not gonna let
those people take over the country I
think that's the level it works and to
dip into dipped on it and to give Donald
Trump is do I think he understands that
because he's a guy who thinks that
global warming is a Chinese hoax but he
knows how to attach derogatory nicknames
to people and that's a lot of his
success in politics yes
the sanitization of the social media
sites given a kid puts beautiful
pictures of themself on the site and
then another kid looks at it and feels
that their life is less than that
beautiful sanitization is that affecting
them as well and creating a lot of this
anxiety absolutely and that's probably
the main reason why it's affecting the
girls so much more than the boys because
if you if you imagine you know all the
kids in America around 2007 to 2009 you
suddenly just dropped millions and
millions of iPhones all over the country
and kids pick them up what do the boys
gonna do Oh video games and it turns out
actually video games aren't that harmful
and it's worn well no really yeah and
that's not a joke
Motors yeah yeah Oh doc
but just to finish up here so the boys
are mostly doing video games which
aren't so bad even if they're running
around imaginary worlds killing people
as my son does with his friends it's
really cooperative there's teamwork
they're talking but what the girls are
doing what the girls are doing is
putting something out and then waiting
anxiously while people comment on it and
so it's it's the social comparison it's
the fear of missing out also girls
bullying is relational boys bullying is
physical so social media that doesn't
really affect it but girls can never get
away if they're being bullied so this is
why we think the the the suicide rate is
up 25% for boys but it's up 70% for
girls